inflation is the highest it's been in 40
years and there's all sorts of stupid
hot takes rolling around the internet i
came across an article though from
bloomberg that caught my attention and
it said the blackrock president has
warned of inflation's dramatic effects
with an entitled generation now learning
what it means to suffer from shortages
what the hell are these guys talking
about inflation doesn't just hurt any
one group it actually hurts everybody it
doesn't matter what your education level
is your income level or anything else
everyone is affected by inflation it's
not just one simple generation but again
if we start thinking about inflation as
an invisible tax then i started to think
maybe he actually was talking about
something different so i went and i
looked for the actual quote what the
hell is the blackrock president talking
about well the quote was for the first
time this generation is going to go into
a store and not be able to get what they
want and we have a very entitled
generation that has never had to
sacrifice what the hell is he talking
about this generation's grown up for 20
years we were engaged in two global wars
we marched our men and women off to die
on the battlefield on top of that in
2008 and 2009 was a global financial
crisis many of this generation were
actually just coming out of college the
labor market was horrendous they
couldn't find a job on top of that they
hold financial assets like bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies that have suffered four
five six different 50 plus percent
drawdowns over the last couple of years
they've also suffered through two to
three different 80 plus percent
drawdowns of those same assets they
watched as six plus million people a
week filed for first-time unemployment
claims in 2020 there was a pandemic that
literally had the government force them
to go into lockdown and sit in their
homes and they also watched the stock
market crash 30 percent the same exact
time
and now they're living in historic
inflation it's at a 40-year high the
real inflation rate is likely in the 15
to 20 range there's 11 million open jobs
in america the idea that this generation
is entitled that they haven't had to
suffer that they haven't lived through
bad times is comical this is just
another out of touch person who doesn't
really actually look at the data it
sounds good to say it especially when
you're talking to your peers and
colleagues who tend to be a little bit
older
but ultimately every single person went
through the global financial crisis
every single person lived through the
2020 financial recession every single
person lived through that pandemic and
now every single person is living in a
high degree of inflation
none of this is good rather than point
our fingers at each other maybe what we
should do is try to come up with
solutions on how to fix it because until
we come up with those solutions everyone
regardless of what generation they're
from they're all going to keep suffering
together hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time